now let's get a feel for montreal ron
futrell joins us tonight here in student
ron
you right after peter deboer was hired
you went up to montreal and now he's the
head coach of the night so you've seen
this firsthand this montreal
yes indeed chris we look back on january
2020
and it didn't seem all that remarkable
at the time of course the knights had
made a coaching change from
gerard gallant to pete deboer but this
was just the second game deboer had ever
coached with the golden knights now the
board took the ice
and the team the coach they were there
just getting ready to know each other a
little bit that january
at the bell center in montreal we're the
only las vegas tv station to be there
for this
now we're going to say historic event
this was actually the last time the two
teams have met
less than two months later both
countries went into coven lockdown
many things had changed it's only now
that the knights have gone back to 100
attendance montreal is still in lockdown
also to give you a sense of the history
of the canadians back then
i did this piece on the captain's wall
at the bell center arena in montreal
okay an interesting wall here in
montreal
that shows the captains of the canadians
over the years 30 captains over their
100 year history
100 plus and we'll take a look at a few
of them okay oh by the way
the last captain who had before the
current one max pacquiao ready up there
okay nice player was the captain
for the montreal canadiens
pier turjon on this list e carbinol
let's go down the list
oh up top there chris celia so a lot of
people will remember him
as chicago blackhawks player but oh he
was the captain
of the montreal canadiens and also
written in french and english here as
you can see some of the
uh descriptions okay a few others that
stand out of maurice rashard okay let's
go here the rocket
one of the great all-time nhl players
canadian icon
as it says here led the halves of the
santa clamp in each of his four seasons
each of four seasons for the four
seasons with montreal each of those
seasons he wins the stanley cup
didn't know that they've got 58 people
in the hall of fame won 24 stanley cups
the first guy jack laviolette okay no i
didn't know the name but i didn't
read the description here he was he was
a general manager head coach
played forward defenseman and even was
the goalie for a while
with the canadians so there you go a
little history here of the nhl and
hockey
one of these days 100 years from now
we'll have this sort of wall up at the
t-mobile arena now they don't have
captains right now i don't know if
that's going to change
they don't have a captain with the
knights yet but they'll probably get
with that at some point and start doing
that with captains
on the team but this is the captain
history of the montreal canadiens
over 100 plus years
of course since we did that story in
january last year chris the knights now
have a captain of course mark stone
and yes they should start captain's wall
before too long
at t-mobile arena just one picture now
but there'll be more to come
hey ron when you think of the canadians
you think of hockey you don't think of
the expos the alouettes of the canadian
football league
but you think of hockey and you were
telling me that the traditions up there
and the
the arena up there is kind of similar to
the fortress here
oh they com they compare them to vegas
they they were compared to vegas they've
been around for
more than 100 years and they were
talking about how loud they are
the show that they put on beforehand the
fans enthusiasm
now they are the best way to call them
they're the yankees
of the nhl in that sense so if it makes
sense with from a baseball comparison
is they have won so many titles and
that's the way a lot of people look at
them
but they have not won a championship
since 1993 92-93 season when they beat
gretzky and the la kings i'll have more
on that this week that i'm not happy
about when that series and how that
happened but
we got plenty of time for that kevin
over to you